accomplissez une fonction de protection
rapprochée du président de la république
pour être tout à fait exact
j'ai vu des images bien sûr de monsieur
bénard d'un abus de large
vous savez le mieux la sécurité
rapprochée c'est un milieu complexe il
sans rentrer dans les détails on parle
de deux cercles de responsabilité le
siècle le plus proche de la personnalité
dont on a assuré la protection est prise
en compte par le groupe bleu j'espère
pour le président la république
après on a affaire à des cercles qui
s'éloigne de plus en plus qui sont pris
en compte pas d'autres services de
police et qui constitue un filtre avant
d'arriver jusqu'au président de la
république dans le cercle le plus proche
le métier tels que j'ai eu à l'exercer
par le passé fait qu'on y retrouve bien
sûr d'autres personnes que le président
la république sinon il serait totalement
isolé des gens à qui souhaite rencontrer
avec qui souhaitent avoir un échange
mais on y rencontre également des
conseillers qui ont par leur rôle à
avoir une proximité avec le président de
la république
depuis on y rencontre également des gens
qui fit quelques longs que l'on retrouve
tels que le préfet territorialement
compétent lorsqu'ils accueillent le
président ou l'ambassadeur lorsqu'on est
l'ambassadeur de france lorsqu'on est à
l'étranger et c'est vrai que la sécurité
rapprochée doit composer avec ces
personnes qui rentrent dans ce cercle
quand je vois l'image du président
macron avec monsieur benalla proximité
il m'est difficile de dire s'il est
présent à ses côtés en tant que membre
de son cabinet ou membres de sa sécurité
pour pouvoir vous répondre
il faudrait que une une action se
déroule à savoir qu'il fallait opérer
une évacuation du président de la
république pour voir à ce moment là
qu'ils agiraient et que ferais tu il
aujourd'hui
la présence à proximité immédiate du
président de la république d'un certain
nombre de passes de personne ne peut pas
déterminer à coup sûr son rôle
je vous ai cité toutes les personnes qui
prouve qu'on pouvait trouver dans
l'environnement immédiat du président la
république qui rentre dans le cercle que
j'ai évoqués on y trouve aussi ce que
j'appelle moi des parasites des gens qui
sont des courtisans
on trouve à proximité de prison la
république yeux constitue une gêne qui
nous appartient de l'évacuer parfois
d'éloigner pour pouvoir exercer cette
fonction
donc aujourd'hui je ne ne peux pas dire
sans qu'il y ait eu une réaction du
groupe de sécurité du président de la
république quel aurait été son rôle
on a des gens qui sont dans ce cercle
pour leur mission de sécurité rapprochée
d'autres pour leur mission de conseiller
au cabinet d'autres pour des missions de
représentation
depuis d'autres des membres de la
population qui sont là pour pouvoir
s'adresser au président de la république
donc au premier regard il est difficile
d'identifier qui fait quoi
encore une fois il aurait fallu que
d'une action dramatique se déroule pour
prend connaître pour connaître le rôle
de chacun merci de cette réponse très
circonstancié monsieur jean pierre sueur
elle a juste sur ce point monsieur le
préfet nous avons eu des informations
selon lesquelles il y aurait en fait 2,7
pour ce qui est de la proximité en radio
du chef de l'état un cercle assez large
qui est celui que vous avez décrit et un
autre le composant le comportant que
quatre personnes
celle qui exerce effectivement la
sécurité rapprochée et qui sont au titre
du gspr affectés à cette sécurité très
ultra rapprocher est ce que vous vous
avez vécu le fait qu'il y ait ces deux
cercles ou est-ce que ça n'existait pas
quand vous exercez vos fonctions qui a
été créée depuis semaine à la sécurité
projet est affaire de moments d'instants
j'ai parlé de moments privés et de
moments public elle est aussi affaire d'
analyse de la menace est donc le
dispositif qui est mis en oeuvre autour
du président la république dépendent
beaucoup de cette menace est de 7,2 cet
instant ce qui est certain c'est que
quelle soupe quel que soit le gspr dont
on pourrait parler c'est que le cercle
le plus proche du président de la
république est constitué de membres du
j'espère exclusivement
un pliage de le cercle alors après il y
à d'autres cercles autour il ya 1,2
alors le cercle qu'ont utilisés
habituellement demande à mon époque et
je crois que c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui
il était constitué d'un triangle avec un
élément avancé un élément évacuateur est
un élément de contrôle arrière avec un
kevlar assadi mallette en kevlar à sa
disposition pour protéger le président
lorsqu'on était dans une ambiance avec
beaucoup de foule ou avec une menace
avérée ce triangle pouvait se compléter
d'un quart et qu'on appelait carré
tireur toujours mis en oeuvre par le
j'espère et après on avait à faire des
cercles plus éloignés mais moi quand je
parle le cercle plus éloignées on
s'attache à ce moment-là à d'autres
services de police qui viennent
participer à la sécurité du président la
république de plus de manière plus
générale et ça et à ce moment par les
services de police ou de gendarmerie
locaux qui dont le cercle dont je parle
peut aller jusqu'à un kilomètre autour
puisque le contrôle d'accès à la salle
où par exemple le président s'exprime ou
ou la salle qu'ils visitent
il ce premier contrôle fait partie de la
sécurité du président de la république
elle vient s'ajouter ce dispositif
donc pour moi je le redis le siècle le
plus proche n'est constituée et demandé
à mon époque il n'était constituée
exclusivement de membres du j'espère il
peut il pouvait y avoir un deuxième
cercle technique constitué de ce qu'on
appelait un carré tireur je supplie de
répondre à une agression toujours
constitué de membres du j'espère et à
l'extérieur d'autres services de police
ou de gendarmerie pouvez compléter ce 10